نتحدث الان عن كيف استفاقت هاتاي صباح
اليوم استفاقت على حجم دمار هائل اضافي
الى الدمار الذي خلفه الزلزال المدمر قبل
اسبوعين عمليات المسح
للبنايات التي تضررت من قبل سلطات التركيه
كانت قد اعلنت بانها بلغت ثلاث ملايين وتم
تحديد اشكال هذه يعني الاضرار التي طالت
البنايات بين
يعني متهالكه متضرره نوعا ما شديده الضرر
ولكن اليوم يبدو الامر انه كل تلك
البنايات صارت الان شديده التضرر وهي الان
ايله للسقوط في ايه لحظه لاحظنا استنفار
كبير جدا منذ ساعات الاولى لنهار اليوم
هنا من قبل
رجال الانقاذ وعمليات ازاله الردوم وايضا
رجال الامن والجيش المنتشر بشكل كبير في
هذه المدينه تم تطويق عدد كبير من الاحياء
التي كانت قبل يومين مفتوحه امام الماره
والسيارات الاسعاف ومختلف الاطقم التي
تجوب المدينه في مساعده عمليات الانقاذ
لكن اليوم تم غلق الكثير منها يعني تحسبا
وخشيه وقوع حوادث انهيارات لهذه المباني
التي تصدعت بشكل كبير جراء الزلزال الجديد
او الزلزالين اللذين ضربا المنطقه ليله
امس